911. Très bien, on va suivre ça,
merci Charlotte.
(en ukrainien)
En Ukraine, les habitants
de Kherson sont en liesse.
Ils ont accueilli en héros
les soldats ukrainie o o o ont
libéré leur ville de l'armée
russe. La fin d'une occupation
qui a commencé aux premiers
jours de la guerre.
Jean-Philippe Hughes.
(cris)
- Ils sont accueillis en héros,
portés par les résidents
de Kherson aujourd'hui libérés.
Les tatatatant immortalisent
ce point tournant dans
la reconquête entamée cet été.
"Gloire aux forces armées
ukrainiennes", entonnent
les civils rassemblés dans
les rues, visiblement émus.
Le drapeau jaune et bleu flotte
à nouveau sur la seule capitale
régionale ukrainienne tombée
aux mains de l'envahisseur.
"Ukrainiens, c'est une journée
historique, s'exclame
le président Zelensky.
Nous regagnons le sud du pays,
nous regagnons Kherson."
Mais derrière les crisvivivivie
retrouve son chez-soi,
qui porte désormais l'empreinte
de la dévastation russe.
Une destruction qui a emporté
le principal pont qui relie
Kherson et la rive est
de la rivière Dniepr,
où sont maintenant repliés
les troupes de Vladimir Poutine.
Plus de 30 000 militaires
russes ont quitté la ville,
admet le Kremlin, qui refuse
toutefois de reconnaître
le retour de Kherson
sous juridiction ukrainienne.
PIERRE ST-CYR, col. retraité,
FAC, et ex-attaché de défense
- Le fait de se retirer
du côté est, c'est vraiment
un désaveu de leur puissance,
c'est vraiment un échec.
- Un retrait qui a toutes
les apparences d'une f
désespérée, comme en témoignent
les armes abandonnées.
JUSTIN MASSIE, prof. sc. pol.,
UQAM, réseau d'analyse strat.
- La Russie ne peut pas gagner
cette guerre. n n n n n n voie
de défaite. C'est quelque chose
qui est inéluctable, vu le désir
de résistance des Ukrainiens,
d'une part, et vu le soutien
occidental, d'autre part.
(cris d'acclamation)
- Cette nouvelle victoire
militaire galvanise
les Ukrainiens et fait naître
l'espoir d'une reconquête
avant l'arrivée de l'hiver.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Céaéaéaéaéaéaéa